he's known literally throughout the
Universe for his groundbreaking
discoveries in the field of string
theory he co-invented mirror symmetry
and he brought the notion of calabi Yao
manifolds to the mainstream meet the one
and only Brian Green Brian's a professor
of physics and math at Columbia
University and the author of numerous
best-selling books join us on this
in-person
conversation held late at night at
Columbia University as we uncover the h
reality of our universe and delve into
parallel universes and the Deep
Mysteries of the fabric of reality let's
go here we are today with a man that
needs no introduction fellow Brian oh my
my mom at least claims she named me
Brian so people are confused with brain
I don't know about you but yeah I
haven't heard that one directly but uh
now they uh we have the two of the three
Brians of course I'm I'm the least well
known of them but Brian Cox is of course
the the ultimate also another Brian who
gets a lot of attention maybe he'll come
on someday but so far he's ignored my
messages unlike you and I want to
express my gratitude last time I was in
these luxurious Offices here at Columbia
University I was beseeching you for an
encomium on my book losing the about I
remember that yeah which you graciously
provided back in 2016 and the book came
out in 2018 so I want to appreciate you
and Express gratitude for for all that
you've done for me personally and for
the field of astronomy and cosmology and
science communication thank you very
much Brian for joining us well thank you
one of my most requested if not the most
requested guests and have a ton of stuff
to talk about today we run out of uh
I'll run out of energy and adrenal
system excretions before we run out of
questions I'm sure but we'll see how far
we get the first thing I want to do is I
since I'll introduce you later but I
want to ask what is in your estimation I
call this the experimental minimum I've
had on Lenny suskin before and he's
written books the theoretical minimum I
want to ask you what should a
theoretical physicist cosmologist what
should she or he know about experimental
physics and why well look none of what
we develop theoretically has any real
value if it doesn't make contact
ultimately with experiment and
so my quick answer would be no as much
experiment as you possibly can right
because that is the way in which you can
make contact between abstract math
matics and the actual physical world but
the reality of course is there's a
limited amount of time that any graduate
student any undergraduate any faculty
member has and so you need to know the
basics for cosmology microwave
background
radiation evidence for expansion of the
universe evidence for the accelerated
expansion of the universe you should
know something about black holes you
should know the observational evidence
from motions of stars in the Milky Way
galaxy to the eventor rizing telescopes
actual images of black holes if you
don't know about that stuff people will
look at you kind of weird and you know I
think it's also really good to know the
basics of particle physics right I mean
you should know the standard model of
particle physics you should understand
the experiments that give rise to the
gauge symmetry of the standard model and
you should understand that in 2012 we
confirmed the higs particle you should
know that super symmetry is not yet been
confirmed that's an important
experimental null result and beyond that
you should understand that there is this
mismatch
between our calculations of dark energy
which really comes from understanding
the quantum physics of Elementary
particles and the observational evidence
for dark energy that I would call
perhaps the minimum no doubt there are
other things that should be included but
that's a good start yeah then this
building have been renowned and this
campus have been renowned uh purveyors
of both Theory and experiment I'm
thinking about Robie and and of course
cswo and and of course uh uh you know
all the many great experimentalists and
and theoreticians who have come through
this building and I see it as a as sort
of and I believe arnal penus was a
student here wasn't he I didn't know
that I think he was I'm not I'm not sure
well we have to fact check serious but a
student yeah that could well be yeah
that would have been a long time ago
many of them came through here
and I I think about kind of what do I
want my graduate students to know as
experimentalist for me I say you
shouldn't have to do Theory but you
should know Theory as well as an
incoming graduate student otherwise and
no offense to Plumbers out there Lenny
susin as you know was a plumber but
you're kind of just doing plumbing and
microwave electronics and and that's
very important and interesting stuff but
you're a technician and you can get paid
a lot more in you know free industry
actually I was talking to Jim Simons
recently who's the benefactor of course
of the Simons uh Observatory and I
believe he's supports the W
world he and Maryland are huge champions
of all the great work you and Tracy do
but um but he was saying you know once
he had a call a plumber in the middle of
the night and the plumber came over and
uh fixed up the thing and the sink and
stuff and by this time Jim was in his
hedge fund career and the plumber said
that'll be $700 please and Jim's like
I'm one of the richest guys in the world
but this is ridiculous $700 you know I'm
a hedge fund manager you know you make
$700 for 15 minutes the guy say oh
you're a hedge fund manager yeah that's
that's what I used to make when I was a
hedge fund manager um but when you think
about you know technicians and and so
forth you should understand the why I
believe of what you're doing and so I
want them to understand the theory but
not necessarily to do it and it's always
kind of been curious to me because when
we let a theorist on those occasions
come into my lab we had Katie Freeze
over uh just about a week or two ago and
we don't let them into the lab because
they're always you know they're going to
touch something fiddle with something
but in reality I think there is sort of
a mismatch between what the artian do
and I wonder if you could get into that
what do you do as a theorist not like
saying you know than for your supper but
what does a theorist spend his or her
day doing and I realize you know every
the's different and I'll get a different
answer when I talk to Janna but tell me
what Brian what do you do as as your
craft as scientist well it's an
interesting way of framing it what do
you do dayto day because the day-to-day
changes drastically regarding depending
on what project you happen to be
involved in but I would say the general
rhythm is you read papers that others
have written in order to get a feel for
the state-ofthe-art in whatever problem
you're interested in and more often than
not when you read somebody else's paper
and you see things from a different
perspective it inspires all sorts of new
ideas that you the individual theorists
can begin to pursue and what does that
mean you begin to say hey they did this
calculation what if we were to change
this that or the other and redo the
calcul Cal what would that yield or hey
they did this calculation in this
context but wait a second I remember
this other problem from a couple years
ago and I think that if I take that
calculational method and adapt it to
that other problem there may be
something interesting to do and so it's
a variety of incremental steps that are
often seated by the community it's
usually not the Albert Einstein off at
the patent office coming up with this
radically new idea really I get emails
all the time that I'm we do yes and and
and you know Einstein did a lot of great
things for science but working in the
patent office at least from the
perspective of modern-day physicist was
a real disservice and I mean that in the
following way that you already
understand which is so many people think
you don't need to be within the
community you can be off in left field
just having big thoughts and you'll
change the world on occasion that
happens happens it certainly happened
once and you know a handful of other
times but for most of us we're embedded
in a community and there's an ongoing
conversation sometimes it's a real
conversation sometimes it's reading
other people's papers and so day-to-day
that's what we do we are pursuing
mathematical developments and trying to
see what Insight we can extract from
them hey friends I'll keep this pretty
short but I've been doing some data
analytics on previous episodes that are
related to the topic of string theory
including one with my friend and Brian's
friend cin vafa and when he was on last
time you see at the bottom there it says
the watch time from subscribers versus
unsubscribers means that more than half
of you aren't subscribed to the channel
and yet you're enjoying the videos and
that's just not right no I'm just
kidding I would really love it though if
you would consider subscribing because
it really helps me get some of the
guests that we're getting on and we're
poised to get some phenomenal guests but
when their agents or their publishers
look at podcasts they have to say well
is this worth me sending my beloved
author or thinker to appear on and a lot
of times they do that unfortunately just
based on sheer number of subscribers so
I wonder if you could do me a favor it
would really help a lot if you would
subscribe and I promise in doing so
you'll help me help you uh bring the
best guests to this podcast that we can
possibly get and onward into 2024 and
Beyond so I really appreciate your help
in helping us grow the podcast now back
to the conversation with Brian Green so
you're no doubt familiar with the fact
that string theory has come under attack
and and you've been actually gracious
and kind enough to participate in
debates with past guests on the podcast
like Eric Weinstein and and of course
you know Peter white and and many others
that have alternative theories
alternatives to string theory and you
did your thesis I believe in 1986 on
string theory which is you know kind of
the salad days and I want to ask you if
you had to appraise a prize String
Theory I asked Mike Turner about
inflation and dark energy recently gave
him the same thing give strength Theory
a grade A report card and break it down
into the sub categories of strength
where is it conceeded where does it need
more work and where is the parent
teacher conference GNA happen the only
reason I'm laughing is because the 25th
and this is not a plug folks so it
doesn't matter but it's just because you
asked question the 25th anniversary
edition of the elegant universe is
coming out in August and on the final
pages of this new chapter I've read WR I
give String Theory a report card so part
of me is like hey I don't really want to
spill the beans right here but but I'll
give you a rough feel for it so it's a
good way of phrasing it because you need
to judge a theory among uh many
different criteria right and and some
strength the's done extremely well and
some it hasn't done as well so let me
start with this stuff where it hasn't
done as well when it comes to making
contact with
experimental data the very question that
we began with Str Str year is not as far
along as I would have hoped right so
back in 1986 I don't want to calculate
how many years ago that was it was a
long time ago and if you would have
asked me then and I think most strength
the at the time
2023 are we going to know through
experiment or observation whether these
ideas are correct 95% of the community
said of course we'll know by then and
yet here we are and and we don't know so
on that I would give a relatively low
grade but I'm going to come back to how
I'll give the final grade on that in
just a second because the theoretical
developments in string theory have been
so astonishingly powerful well beyond
anything that I would have anticipated
back in
1986 and one development in particular
that no doubt you know something about
because it's the most famous development
in the last 20 years this ads CFT
correspondence with by by Juan Mala and
actually again it's a whole great it's a
whole community of people of course but
Juan wrote the paper that really took
the World by storm the relevance of that
well it's got a huge degree of relevance
but the relevance to the experimental
question is interesting because once we
learned as we did with Juan's Insight
that string theory is not as a radical
separation from previous methodology as
we once thought which is a great
development a deep connection to older
techniques that are still at the
Forefront because there're are most
powerful techniques Quantum field Theory
once you learn that Quantum field Theory
and string theory are joined at the hip
which is what onean showed us Quantum
field theory is the
most powerfully tested theory in the
history of of particle physics in the
history of quantum mechanics it's a
framework that works tested in what
sense tested in terms of internal
consistency philosophical expediency in
what way has it been I'm talking flat
footed here take the standard model of
particle physics it's a particular
Quantum field Theory and that particular
Quantum field Theory makes predictions
that we can confirm I mean the uh you
know take the Magnetic Moment of the
electron right decimal yeah that's is
that not the most insane I think it's
the most accurately known number yeah so
so so think about the fact that you can
do a calculation using this framework of
quantum Theory it agrees to Observation
to that many decimal places right so so
that's the sense in which these ideas
have been rigorously tested when you
learn that that
framework is intimately connected to the
framework of string theory that they're
not these two radically different things
which is what we initially thought it
doesn't prove string theory of course
but it shows you that we are within the
same universe of ideas all of a sudden
and that to me mitigates to some extent
that string theory has not not gone as
far as we had hoped to actually make an
experimental prediction that we can
confirm but the fact that it has joined
together with the most experimentally
tested approach that is good that's
strong so one of my you know favorite
canards is that I feel like you and I'm
gonna say this you know some of my best
friends are theorists you know I don't
know if I'd let my daughter marry a
theor but anyway the the the point of
you know string theory and all of
experimental or all of science within
this context scientific method is to
make some connection with reality yeah
as you call it the fabric of reality so
beautifully and poetically um but I feel
like some of your ilk have and including
I when I talked to Shelley glashow on
the podcast a couple years ago I said
this to him as well I feel like many of
your colleagues not you necessarily have
put what I call the toe before the gut
in other words we are searching for a
theory of everything and strength theory
is a candidate Theory of Everything I
believe that's that's safe to say um and
yet and yet necessarily have a br
unified theory that people agree with I
mean Shel had su5 and there many
different instantiations of it but to my
knowledge and I'm just a humble
experimentalist but but tell me why is
there kind of why do we skip yeah know
why aren't there as many people pursuing
in the sociology of science pursuing
guts Grand unified theories which would
maybe can explain the difference between
a theory of everything in a gut but why
are so many people over indexing um toes
versus guts yeah so first of all I don't
use that language much I mean sort of
grand unification certainly but toe
Theory of Everything is a term that I
tend not to use very much really for
sociological reasons that if you're
working on The Theory of Everything then
what is somebody who's not working on it
doing with their time of nothing you
know you know so so I've never really
warmed that idea but of course that's
not the point of your question the
question is where should we be putting
our energy and the way I would say it is
this if Shell's su5 or if the other
Grand unified theories like so10 for the
people who are not in the know these are
just names of certain symmetry
principles that equations can satisfy
and we've learned that symmetry is vital
to formulating the laws of physics and
as we went further along in physics we
invoked ever more robust symmetries and
those are two examples of them had those
theories borne fruit that is had their
predictions been directly confirmed
which could have happened right because
georgei glasow and their approach it
predicted their Gran unification Theory
predicted that the pro T should Decay
and as we all know we search for that de
no sign yet waiting so that that so that
was certainly I think sociologically why
people didn't just put all their energy
into going in that particular direction
but I think that the the deeper answer
is that we've come to
realize that to go further in physics
you've got to understand how gravity and
quantum mechanics coexist and all of the
work on Gran unification ignored the
force of gravity that was not the way
that people were pursuing the next step
in our understanding of physics and so
to leave out gravity is to leave out an
essential part of the story and when
String Theory came along and provided a
means for putting gravity and quantum
mechanics together that was deeply
alluring to so many people because now
all of a sudden you weren't leaving
anything out so it could be the biggest
unification of all and moreover when we
began to study string Theory we began to
see the more conventional Grand unified
theories like Georg and glaso su5 and
like S10 we began to see those emerging
from the unification of gravity and
quantum mechanics and so it felt as
though we can have our cake and eat it
too right we can put gravity into the
story and we can unify everything well
let me just push back with love and
respect is I My Hope Is My trademark but
say imagine a counteract history where
Shelly and Weinberg and Abdus are
working and they say well we're not
going to look at electure week
unification until we can incorporate
gravity and the strong force into it
wouldn't we have been a styed in flamu
for an additional who knows how he could
still be looking for electure week
indication two quick answers to that one
is absolutely right so I would never
Advocate that every single theorist goes
along and tries to get the big prize of
putting gravity and quantum mechanics
together so so certainly I I would say
that you do need people who are more
phenomenologically oriented trying to
come up with theories that are closer to
data and that's of course what glashow
Salam and Weinberg were doing that was a
time when the particle physics data was
right there it was right ready to talk
about how do you put electromagnetism
and the weak nuclear force together
because after all it was what you know
1979 I think is when they get their
Nobel priz but the paper itself was in
the early 70s well late 60s is glash out
and and then early 70s so it was only
seven years away or something eight
years away so the theory and the the
experiment were pretty close temporally
speaking so so that's wonderful you need
people who are having this ongoing
dialogue with phenomenology and and
that's that is what was happening today
we are as people often say the victims
of our own success the open questions
are at length scales that are so tiny
energy scales that are so huge that we
simply don't have an accelerator that
within seven years is going to probe the
scales where the open questions
currently lie and that's why we've gone
so far beyond what experimentals can do
and that's why here we are 40 years
later with Str Theory and I don't have
any experiment to show for it well I
wonder how you react to a statement made
by our mutual friend C bafa when he was
on the podcast a couple years ago I said
the same thing which is a canar that we
experimentalists use to tease you
brilliant theorist we said you know
String Theory hasn't made any testable
predictions or connection to he said
Brian you're wrong and he's such a
gentleman as you know he said Brian
you're wrong string theory predicts the
mass of the electron I said holy cow
tell me more and he goes within String
Theory it's possible to come out with a
calculation that shows the mass of the
electron should be between something
like 10us one plank masses to 10 Theus
30 plank masses there 30 words he said I
know that's not good and it's like me
saying to you you weigh less than you
know 10 to the 26 kilograms which I
think is accurate but not precise yeah
um and so when you when you hear things
like that as an experimentalist I feel
like it's hopeless and I would only
think that well to what extent should we
continue to over IND or index on a young
Brian Green you know going into ke going
into this field where uh where
sociologically we can ignore but but
just in terms of intellectual
satisfaction of having something
complete and and and and visceral that
you could accomplish in six to seven
years yeah I think that's all all good
questions and let me just jump off from
what cin said I mean kin's you know a
dear friend and one of the most
brilliant people so and I know exactly
where he is coming from on that
particular answer but I can well well
imagine how it doesn't feel a satisfying
as you had hoped when he ini said it so
so let me give another unsatisfying
answer that that one can give too I'm
sure you of course heard it before
String Theory does make a prediction it
predicts the existence of gravity now
before anybody rolls their eyes there's
something really really deep here which
is the following you a moment ago said
imagine an alternative counterfactual
history where you Salam and Weinberg and
and and glasha hadn't done their work in
what would have happened imagine another
counterfactual another possible Universe
where there wasn't an Albert Einstein
who came up with the general theory of
relativity okay but imagine instead that
we found String Theory by working on
string theory which does not have
gravity manifestly in its equations from
the get-go String Theory truly is a
theory that describes the motion of
vibrating filaments there's no gravity
in there per se right but if you study
string Theory the mathematics of it you
find that there's a vibrational pattern
of a string which has exactly the right
properties to be the quantum mechanical
conveyor of the gravitational force
which means when you study the motion
and properties of this particular
vibrating string you study it close
enough and you find Einstein's equations
you find Einstein's equations Einstein
had to spend 10 years from first
principles banging his head against a
black board to try to learn differential
geometry and to come up with the remon
equ you know and all of this deep
differential geometry and he comes up
with the Einstein equations had he not
done that we wouldn't have had it but
had String Theory come along and people
studied it they would have extracted
what we now call the Einstein equations
from the theory so that's pretty darn
deep right there and yeah sorry I was
going to say is is that in a similar
vein that you could derive Newton's
equations or even classical mechanics
from quantum mechanics is it or is it
completely different uh it depends so so
if you're talking about how you can get
sort of something akin to f equals ma
from Schrodinger Einstein Newton's
theory of universal gravitation yeah so
I don't know how to get that from
quantum mechanics I do know how to get f
equals ma from quantum mechanics F equ
I'm sorry yeah I was maybe complaing two
different things I was asking the first
te analogy I asked was can you get it in
the same way that you're saying you can
derive yeah Einstein 's gr from String
Theory can you also is it in the same
vein technically mathematically as the
way that we can derive Newton's law of
gravitation from from GR in other words
would you predict does can you also say
does it predicted in the same sense that
gr predicts Newton so so in in a sense
yes right but um the difference is in
the string theory context you
are unifying Einstein with Quantum
mechanic
Einstein I should say it's a clal
emerging from Quant yeah and then you're
pulling out from that the classical
gravitational equations that Einstein
wrote down and so many of us find that
to be you know is it really a prediction
in the conventional sense of go out and
look for this no it's a postdiction we
certainly knew about gravity and Ein
equations beforehand but you know had
let me ask you let me ask you this
question had we had no Einstein and had
we had string theory and some string
theorists pulled out of string theory
Einstein's equation and made a
prediction for the bending of Starlight
and then we went out and measured during
a solar eclipse the bending of Starlight
and it was confirmed wouldn't you feel
oh my God string theory is the right
right wouldn't that be where you go so
in this other history yeah the
counterfactual the green counteract
history I would be forced to at least
grapple with it I think the ultimate
base level of the fabric of reality to
use your poetic language it would be
less satisfying less nourishing
intellectually than say discovering
these extra dimensions in say a particle
exist because you could also maybe
extrapolate the other way could you get
Quantum field Theory from from string
theory if it counterfactually you know
swinger wasn't in this building and and
didn't come up with finean and Tanga and
he didn't come up with QED could you get
that emerging from Str I assume the
answer and and the answer is yes hey
everyone we're talking about space and
time in this episode with my good friend
Brian Thanksgiving season is upon us and
as you can tell I'm very thankful my
kids favorite Brian appeared on into the
impossible for many Thanksgiving means
good old American traditions like family
turkey dinners football arguing with
your loved ones and of course Black
Friday discounts my favorite day on the
calendar and if you spend a lot of time
on your computer like I do you need to
check out the Black Friday deals that
app Sumo has on software tools all the
deals are available right now until
December 1st this deal covers all sorts
of software C courses and more and the
discounts are huge as big as the
universe I'm looking at their website
right now appsumo
docomo this is truly an impossibly good
deal and for me this Black Friday I'll
treat myself to a tasty treat tidy cow
which helps me m manage my calendar
easily and efficiently and it will do so
for you too how do you think I stay in
touch with all my guests back and forth
it's just like calendly without the
price tag as you can expect balancing my
professorial duties with podcasting gets
a little bit tricky and this product is
going to help me stay focused and
organized so I get everything done on
time personally I've used calendly a lot
in the past but it's pretty basic and in
my opinion it's overpriced tidy cow has
the same cool Integrations and almost
infinite customizability it's remarkably
easy to use plus it's a lifetime deal so
no more monthly payments regardless of
whether you use it or not for a onetime
super low price you can get lifetime
access so you can finally Master the
fabric of reality at least regarding
your personal time anyway and tidy Cal
isn't even a part of the Black Friday
lineup which means that there are 30
plus other tools available with even
bigger discounts for a limited time only
I love apps like this for cutting
through the Clutter and back and forth
scheduling interviews collators friends
and guests and even those occasional
rock stars like today's guest Brian
Green so once again for all of you
listening and watching out there check
out app sumo's Black Friday offers at
appsumo
docomo to appsumo
[Music]
what are the you know classical
emanations from which that we could test
with particle accelerators or
cosmological accelerators which I want
to get into the universe as as a
laboratory so yeah that that is
certainly I think you ask well what is
the difference between you know uh
counterfactual and a or let me say this
a retrodiction or a postdiction and a
prediction I kind of don't believe that
the job of a scientist is just to make
new predictions because there's an
infinite number of things that could be
possible and there's a very very small
you know set of things that are possible
and are test
so you know Einstein's Paran of mercury
anomalous procession of the of the absis
ofan that is a retrodiction but it was
very powerful and then from that yes
there were new things that came along I
think it would be I mean the coolest
thing and I'm going to ask you you know
for other speculations when it comes to
things like string theory or the
Multiverse which are both domains that
you've trafficked in very successfully
but um when we think about what is it
that the goal should be can it be to
make a connection to make something that
I my experimentalist my colleagu can
test in a laboratory or not that's
technologically dependent that's
situationally dependent we wouldn't have
been able to discover and I I love to
read like The the original you like you
were talk about Einstein in the patent
office if you read like Maxwell's
original Trea on electromagnetism hard
to read it's hard to read and the
fuctions and and he's like inventing new
new terminology But ultimately he got
the right answer because he came up with
these four equations that are you know
tattooed on many people's you know
farads in in the space but if you look
at the underlying physics the model for
it it's a bunch of clap trap weirdo ult
stuff with wheels and gears and and
electromagnetic virtue I always joke
like what if he was on Twitter what if
Twitter exists in 1865 and he's like I
got this great Theory and it involves
these whirl pools and Eddies but like
people said you're an idiot like there's
no whirl pools and Eddies we already
know that but but then to look back you
would have thrown the baby out with the
bathat of the electromagnetic virtue
because you put have rejected a correct
Theory and I worry that we're doing that
with stram Theory or I'm worried that in
some sense the nutrients in the earth
there's only so much nutrition so are we
neglecting other models and I guess I
want to ask you I I've asked this of
other people Stephen wlfr Eric Weinstein
uh Garrett leasy whenever I asked them
what do you think not about String
Theory because I know I'm gonna get an
earful about String Theory from all
these gentlemen U but what do you think
about uh competitor B you know what what
does Eric Weinstein think about Garrett
leasy or what does Garrett Ley think
about Peter Wy or or Steven Wilford and
they say I don't have time and I'm like
come on guys you know I I've got little
kids I've got teaching responsibility
I've got an experiment in Chile I'm not
nearly capable to comprehend the
mathematics but at some level you don't
have time I mean strength the your
thesis I'm not going to date you but
it's over over 30 years ago right yeah
um do people really not have time in the
theoretical Community to actually
perview or is it like you only have so
much time so I'm not going to De unless
I could do it to every well I guess what
I would say is when any of these newer
ideas have come online there's usually
some string theorist who has spent some
time on it and if it's someone who I
respect then you know my motivation to
then redo the analysis and try to
confirm what my colleague has concluded
I feel less motivated to do so I'll give
you an example you know I believe it was
with Garrett ley's thing that jacqu dler
do you know him from University of Texas
Aus yeah so jacqu is a brilliant
theorist he and I did we used to work
very closely together way a long time
ago back in the 80s we're still you know
good friends every time we go down there
we hang out and he wrote a variety of
things on on Garrett's ideas and I
perused those and I trust jacqu he's one
of those people I mean it's not like you
go and redo every experiment everybody
does you know so I trust him he's a
thoughtful person and the conclusion
that he reached was there's nothing here
and when I read something like that I'm
like okay you know I don't feel the
motivation when it comes to Steven wolf
I do feel differently I do want to put
some effort in to understanding exactly
what he is saying again I I know him
reasonably well we're we're you know not
best buds but we're friends and uh he's
encouraged me a few times to and he
sends me articles and I am starting for
instance to do that now he and I are
going to do a conversation at some point
then not to distant future so I will be
educating myself on that one you know in
terms of the others Loop quum gravity I
did maybe 15 20 years ago I put a little
bit of time in so I would understand the
basic framework that they were
developing and I found it interesting
it's not in any way crack pot but I
didn't find it sufficiently compelling
and I also didn't like the fact that
unlike String Theory it didn't naturally
incorporate everything all forces you
know again staying away from theory of
everything there is an heal nevertheless
in string theory that it's got the
capacity to to embrace everything so so
on those that's sort of where I stand
did I leave somebody out of the disc
your friend you guys have debated and
had a memorable exchange at the IAA
conference where he said something and
you said well maybe we were over
exuberant he said like the Meli
Massacre as only Eric Weinstein could do
um so his geometric Unity Theory which
features some testable predictions again
I'm an experimental right right so I'm
looking for well what things could we do
say how would the prediction of
Garrett's Theory or Steven's Theory or
Ava Silverstein you know any idea how
will that affect observables that say
the Simon's Observatory can measure one
of the things we can do is measure
abundances we can measure look for spin
dependent uh phenomena and those
theories and I think the thing that Eric
always harps on is that we don't we seem
I I say we collectively as physicists
and I'm including myself uh even though
I'm not a theorist but um in in the
things that seem to not trouble us
troubles Eric in other words why is it
that we have three families of fans and
we don't have an explanation for that we
just we just sort of know it as a
taxonomy and as feineman said just
because you know the name of something
tells you bubus about it right does that
trouble you I mean is that part of hey
if you go back yeah you mentioned my
thesis which I haven't thought about in
a very long time but um you know the
point of that thesis was to try to
answer why there are three generations
from a string theoretic perspective
and way back then there were only a
handful of known shapes for the extra
Dimensions that string theory requires
and in string theory the number of
generations of particles is related to a
geometrical quantity in the extra
Dimensions half the oiler characteristic
for those who are keeping score at home
and so if you have three generations
you're looking for Oiler characteristic
six okay and there were only really
three known examples that had been
constructed around those times and with
a colleague another graduate student at
Oxford we proved that two of them were
actually the same ah so unified so we
unified them so we're sort of down you
know by one and uh I may be a grand
ising but I think we also pulled in the
third one so I think we basically got it
down to one if I'm if I'm I maybe being
generous with myself 40 years later but
it was it was one or two I believe it
was one and so what we did was we then
went further and tried to calculate the
mass of the the electron or the mass of
the other particles from this particular
geometrical form the extra dimensions
and at that time with the limited
mathematical understanding which has
since become much more deep we got
partway down that road but as we did
more and more shapes for the extra
Dimensions were discovered so all of a
sudden this motivation to study one well
if there're only four or five total and
only one with three generations of
course you're going to study it but then
when they're 500 or 10,000 or 10 to the
500 your motivation for studying any
specific example drops precipitously so
that is the historical way but yes does
it does it intrigue me this question of
why there are three generations
absolutely when I interviewed Nick
Bostrom you know who so I asked I said
to him he's from Sweden I said look Nick
you know you're from you're from Sweden
and if I had on you know ABA if I had
them on the into the impossible podcast
and I did not ask them to play dancing
it would be a a complete dereliction of
the podcaster oath which you and I have
swor to I have to ask you cabia
manifolds because I'm here with at least
you know the the foremost prop uh you
know proprietor of of all things cabia
what is a Cabo what is a manifold how
does it have to do with the fabric of
reality sure could you could you enjoin
us with this uh with this no doubt
delightful explanation from The
Godfather yeah I mean very briefly so I
think as many people know when we
studied the equations of string theory
even as far back as you know the the
1970s it became very clear that the
theory required more than the three
spatial Dimensions that we all see in
the world around us indeed we needed six
additional spatial Dimensions that we
don't see how do we explain them this
goes way back to kuta and Klein in the
early part of the 20th century just
imagine that the extra dimensions are
here but they're crumpled to a size
that's so small that we can't detect it
with the naked eyeon perhaps even with
our most powerful magnifying equipment
even with accelerators perhaps it's just
too small good so that's why the
dimensions would be tiny but then you
say to yourself can you curl them up in
any which way or are there mathematical
restrictions on the geometrical shape of
the extra dimensions and indeed there
are these restrictions and the
particular kind of restriction that
people began to study in the 1980s was
to demand that the preserved this thing
called super symmetry which we made
reference to very briefly before not
finding it at the large hron collider
but in any event the goal was to
preserve this symmetric quality of the
equations and when you impose that you
find that the extra Dimensions have to
be curled up into this so-called cab Yao
shape or cabia manifold manifold is
really just a geometrical shape there's
some technical details but that's the
basic idea and so what is a cabia shape
or manifold well it's a it's a manifold
manold that
preserves or perhaps I should say it in
the following way it's a manifold that
is as close as you can be to being flat
without literally being a flat shape so
you might say well what does that mean
but in Six Dimensions you can have
something which is known as Richie flat
it's a kind of flatness that was
developed in the early days of
differential geometry and so you can
have the shape that's as close as it can
be to being and yet not literally being
flat itself for those who want to know a
little bit more detail the idea is if
you take a a vector on this space and
you parallel transport it around any
Loop it comes back to itself up to a
symmetry transformation and that
symmetry transformation is demanded to
line a particular group and what is that
group that group is su3 so that's the
idea of this particular kind of shape
which solves the equation of string
theory and preserve super symmetry at
low energy do those have Oiler
characteristic six or do they they can
have a whole variety of Oiler
characteristics and so as we've studied
these more and more the range of numbers
has grown but roughly speaking call the
oiler characteristics a number between
you know that that that's less than say
a thousand it can be negative it can be
positive so there are a lot of
possibilities in there Oiler
characterist six would be the preferred
number if you're trying to make contact
with particle physics as we know it and
over the years more and more of the or
character six possibilities have been
developed do we know there will be no
other forces you know discovered I mean
we hear about these fifth forces yeah
those are sort of esoteric in the in the
forc space I you know if the muon has
this anomalous moment then it might be
mediated by these virtual particles
which themselves would be byproduct of
bons which are the gauge you know Force
mediators honest to goodness forces I
mean do you do you believe there are you
know possibilities that there could be
something as Manifest as as gravity or
or Yang Mills or or whatever that we
would identify that's an honest to
goodness force or can we not say right
now that we will never or we will ever
discover a new force a new proper Force
so there's sort of two answers to that
question one is in string theory proper
there are many versions of the theory
that do give rise to other forces
for the most part these forces aren't
manifest at the energy scales that we
have access to so they would only come
to life if you will if you're probe in
the universe on incredibly short
distance scales or incredibly High
energies but the other answer is look if
you have additional
forces that most of the particles that
we know about are immune to then those
forces won't have a whole lot to act
upon that we have observational ins
sight into so can you have additional
forces that persist even at low energies
in principle yes now there are bounds
that come to this mostly From
cosmological perspective because there's
a limit to the number of degrees of
freedom that you can have commensurate
with the expansion rate of space and
things of that sort so is it possible
that there are extra forces absolutely
is there any evidence for it no but
string theory has an abundance of
additional forces at higher energies so
back in the the days of yor in 1986 uh
there were two movies that changed my
life tremendously one was Top Gun and
the other one was Back to the Future and
a recent pay-per-view co-written with
our good good friend Jan 11 is shown
here I read through it back to the
future causality on a moving brain world
I want to get into this I want to say
first again thank you for that
explanation Cav and thank you for the
connection between uh three generations
of Fons I want to get from you what is
brain world but before I go there um
what interests me most lately I kind of
most cosmologists sort of assume
inflation or something like inflation
occurred and I often like this term
which actually David Albert your
colleague and our mutual friend told me
actually this thing originally came from
philosophy of science uh but you'll know
it from Natty cyberg who said if
anything comes up you know that looks
like string theory that's not part of
string theory we'll just call it string
theory he said something along those
lines right David said that anything
that uh I think a philosopher of science
that David's like screaming at the
camera now telling because he just told
me 20 you know 20 minutes ago or so but
he said that a philosopher of science
said you know when we discover something
in the philosophy of science uh and then
later it gets incorporated into physics
we just call that physics and say the
philosophers didn't help us at all we'll
talk about philosophy hopefully if you
if you have the energy as as I'm getting
my second win now late at night here in
Upper upper New York P peninsula of
Manhattan Island rather but I want to uh
first ask you
when I look at exciting things to me it
may be that inflation occurred or
something like inflation occurred we'll
get into alternatives to inflation just
a bit but those Alternatives might look
a lot like inflation the alternatives to
string theory might be subsumed within
them but one thing that seems so
different from all you know it's like
the Platypus of of mammals or whatever
is Loren and variance and if we were to
show there was a violation of Loren and
variance uh I think it would be almost a
bigger advance or a bigger crisis in in
science than say proving that inflation
took place or motivating that inflation
took place through CNB studies that I'm
involved what what is your what are your
thoughts about a Lorent inance is it
sacran and maybe you could give a quick
definition some of the work was done by
Madam woo and in this building with
parody violation is is a kind of an
offshoot of laoren and varians what do
laoren and variance why is it central to
string the how does it play a role in
this theory in moving in Back to the
Future yeah so so Loren and baren is is
much much bigger than String Theory you
know it predates it and it is a
fundamental symmetry property of just
about any theory that we take seriously
and the idea really goes back to
Einstein and of course lorence who in
the early years of the 20th century even
actually the later years of the 19th
century were thinking about Maxwell's
equations that you made reference to and
noting that within those equations there
is this deep symmetry principle which in
modern language basically says that any
perspective that's moving at a fixed
speed in a fixed Direction constant
velocity motion is really as good as any
other perspective moving with a
different speed in a different direction
so it's describing an equivalence or
really lack of preferential frame of
reference when you consider the constant
velocity observers that might be examed
in the world and we we do at least in a
local environment consider this to be
sacren symmetry this is what gives rise
to the special theory of relativity this
is what gives rise to the speed of light
being constant the way the Symmetry is
realized light has a special quality of
its speed being fixed and so the data
behind this and the
experimental confirmation of this is so
strong over the past 100 years that
people are would be loathed to give up
this idea but the one thing I want to
stress relevant to our paper is the
Symmetry really is confirmed in a local
sense I mean those are the experiments
that we do we consider some region of
space over some interval of time and
within that region call it the
laboratory call it your home call
whatever yeah you know we we do our
experiments and we establish this to be
true well we considered an our paper is
not whether Lorent Symmetry lorence and
variance would be violated in any local
environment but we wondered what if the
overall Grand structure of SpaceTime is
such that the Symmetry is violated not
locally but only in the global sense
what do I mean by that well imagine that
space doesn't go on forever in a given
Direction imagine that if you go out in
One Direction
you go far enough you wind up returning
to your starting point much as what
would happen on the surface of the Earth
of course and so we imagine that idea
applying to the fabric of space and in
that environment there are subtle
violations of the lent symmetry you
would never detect them locally rather
you'd have to circumnavigate the
universe in some sense the the
laboratory or the bulk or is it a micro
Dimension that you're circumnavigating I
don't care what size the Dimension is
right now so so I'm I'll be agnostic on
the size of this extra Dimension and the
interesting thing is to ask yourself if
you redo Einstein's analysis in a
universe that has this
nontrivial shape for one of the
dimensions how does it change what
Einstein did way back in 1905 for the
special theory of relativity and we
found some surprising results we found
that you can send signals in this
universe at a speed that's actually
greater than light speed is it always
greater or can it be greater can slow
down it can have so so if we get a
little bit more into the detail you
mentioned this idea of a brain yeah
before so that's one of the key ideas
here we imagine that our universe is
living on what I like to poetically
think of as a giant slice of bread that
itself is floating in a larger
environment so imagine everything that
you know just for visualization purposes
takes place on this giant slice of bread
Universe obviously it's only two
dimensions of space but in the real
version it would be three but it's too
hard to picture so let's do this lower
dimensional version and imag that's
right so this slice of bread is called a
membrane or a brain that's where this
idea of brain comes from and it's a very
natural idea in string theory to
Envision that the universe as we know it
takes place on a three-dimensional
membrane but the two-dimensional ver of
the piece of bread is a good one to have
in mind because then you can picture it
but imagine that perpendicular to that
slice of bread is an additional
dimension of space and that our slice of
bread can move in that additional
dimension of space and imagine that that
additional dimension of space has a
circular shape is so in principle this
slice of bread can be moving around this
extra dimension in the shape of a circle
sym1 symetry now here's the interesting
thing if I want to send a signal to my
friend who's far away on our slice of
bread you would think the easiest and
fastest way to do that is send a light
signal along the slice of bread just
ignore the extra Dimension that's just
Superfluous you know if you want to get
there as fast as possible we found
however that if you are moving if your
brain is moving in this extra circular
Dimension there's a faster way to get
the signal to your friend you don't send
the signal right along the piece of
bread you send it in the circular
Dimension allow it to wrap all the way
around the circle and then hit your
friend because it's moving that's it's
Galilean relativity now you're boosting
it well but it's actually it's really
special relativity and and Lorent
symmetry that comes into the story here
when you do the mathematical analysis
but yes in the in the combined rotating
brain along that one special axis yeah
so would there be um anisotropy I mean
would you have this violation also in
spatial yeah you do have you you have a
kind of Left Right violation because
the question is are you moving clockwise
or counterclockwise around the circle
and that can affect the results that you
get in fact it does affect you have
weird time and causality issues like so
causality is the big one because
normally whenever anyone says I can send
a signal faster than the speed of light
which is what we are saying yeah the
response of most physicists will be oh
that's interesting you must be violating
that's right you must be violating
causality because if you can send signal
fast the speed of light we're trained to
conclude that causality must be violated
that training is actually wrong because
here's the thing what you really need to
determine is whether there's so-called
closed timel like curves that is can you
send a signal to your friend and have
your friend send the signal back to you
and have the return signal get to you
before you send the original signal in
the first place because let's say that
return signal killed me MH how would I
be alive to send the original signal in
the first place so we did that
calculation we did the round trip travel
time I send a signal to my friend the
friend returns it to me it will always
get back to me a smidgen of a second
after I've sent the original signal
never get back causality is built in so
yeah I'm reminded a little bit of of you
know famous girdles he also had girle
Universe yeah girdle universe and then I
believe yeah he he sort of went to his
deathbed believing that that was true
and he was a character for sure and um
wow that's that is really F but let me
just answer the other question you
mentioned before you asked me in terms
of how fast can the signals go and so
our calculations show that when I send
the signal to you far away on the brain
the speed of that signal can be
arbitrarily large wow and in fact the
formula for it uses a very famous symbol
called gamma that we all teach to our
special relativity students again I
usually don't talk in mathematics but
why not smartest audence gam one over
the square root of 1 minus v^2 over c^2
now now normally that is a factor that
we use in special relativity to talk
about length contraction you divide by G
or time dilation in this particular case
it enters differently it enters as the
speed of the signal the speed of the
signal is not one over gamma it's Gamma
or gamma times C if I put C back into
the story gamma can be arbitrarily large
and therefore the speed of the signal
can be arbitrarily large now what does
that mean normally when we talk about
the possibility of aliens and I'm just
using this we have to talk about this is
podcasting in 2023 so this is this is
but this is so maybe I shouldn't even
use this langage keep you can't drop the
a bomb all right all right so imagine
there is some extra terrestrial
civilization far away normally we say
well it'd be interesting to know they're
there but we can't really have a
conversation because we'll say hello and
then like 100,000 years later we'll get
the signal and then 100,000 years later
again we'll get the return signal we
won't even remember that we setting up
this podcast with you you're so busy but
exactly so so so so that would suggest
that you know you can't have real-time
communication when the other person at
the other end of the line's too far away
in this approach we could have a
realtime
conversation with a civilization
arbitrarily far away because we can get
the signal there arbitrarily quickly if
we are moving sufficiently quickly in
this extra Dimension and then they can
get it back to us and it will always res
arrive after we sent the signal but it
could be very it could be a second later
so we'll say hey how you doing oh we're
doing fine oh really what's going on
over and and you could in principle in
in this universe now I'm not saying that
this is necessarily our universe I don't
know if there's an extra Dimension I
don't know if there is one it's in the
shape of a circle if it's there I don't
know that we're on a brain moving
through it but what's beautiful to me
about this example is Einstein wrote his
paper and whatever 18 years ago okay one
would have thought that there's nothing
else to extract from thinking about
Einstein's special relativity it's ins
sconed in the textbooks we teach it to
our students it's done with right and
yet by just imagining this little
generalization of Einstein where you
have this extra mention in the shape of
a circle you extract these wonderful new
results so you asked me when we started
what does a theorist do here's what a
theorist does now noral usually we don't
go back to Einstein in 1905 you know got
a lot of emails that Einstein but but
normally that's more in the crack poot
here it is going back to Einstein 1905
and doing rigorous calculations and
coming to something which to me at least
was shockingly unexpected and as I said
I I think I would if you gave me or God
gave me the choice between you know say
verifying that you know inflation is
consistent with you know this production
of gravitational waves from early
Universe tens of peration or you know
which kind of a lot of people assume is
true I actually don't I want to get into
uh cosmological Alternatives but if you
if you assumed you had that choice or
you could prove that Lorent you know
invariance is violated to me that's
that's the holy gril and in fact I want
to get your reaction to this because I
can't resist again we're in this
building uh this historic building uh on
the campus of of Columbia University and
uh chinen Wu and she discovered in the
course of like Christmas break she got
down to three, of a Kelvin in an
apparatus with a radioactive spinning
Cobalt nucleus that she magn just a try
I we can't do that today I mean it's not
like some easy thing that oh you can go
like most of our experiments in our lab
classes at San Diego they're they're
previously you know won Nobel prizes
davidon germer or Milan oil drop or
whatever um this my students are not
going to do it cost a million dollars
just to get a ution for I could possibly
do anyway she verified that that the
actual the weak force is as Maxim parity
violating as possible which you couldn't
you know think of as another kind of
symmetry that that could be respected
under the grand rubric of all possible
symmetries that nature could be expected
to respect we found that
electromagnetism later is Unified with
the weak with with the weak force and
the work of Salam and glasow and
Weinberg that we discussed earlier is it
possible that not only the strong
nuclear force would exhibit uh would
exhibit parody violating properties but
also potentially electromagnetism and
I'm speaking now of things like churn
Simon Cosmic bio fringant and and things
that we're looking for actively and
actually Jim Jim is hoping that we'll
Discover it because you know Brian we
got him an asteroid I got an asteroid
named after JY s great he's got a boat
he's got a plane you know he's done but
the one thing he doesn't have is a Nobel
Prize and so every every year he talks
to his friend Frank Yang gets because
you can nominate people who for the
Nobel Prize if you've already won one
which you know unfortunately I have not
so I can't nominate them and I wrote a
book that's kind of condemning of it but
I want to ask you is it possible that
not only electricity and magnetism might
like violate parity at some level but
gravity because all the forces are
unified if unification is true or if you
don't see it does it mean that
unification is impossible yeah the
bottom line is I have no idea and I
don't think anybody really does you know
again what do theorists do to that
question one of the things that we do is
we take established theories and we add
new terms to them in order to break some
cherished symmetry or some cherished
principle and then try to determine
through mathematical calculations
whether this new term violates something
else that we've already confirmed
experimentally or does it give rise to a
prediction for something that we can go
and look for so there are a gazillion
papers which do this and of course the
challenge to the experimentalist is
which ones do you take seriously enough
to actually put the effort in to try to
test so you know farbe it for me to pass
judgment on you know a whole body of
work where all sorts of symmetry
violating terms have been added to
various theories it's exciting to
imagine that something new and profound
can happen even in the most well tested
theories but I think it unlikely but of
course the prize is huge if the unlikely
thing actually bears fruit so I don't
know uh so I to Pivot from the very
small to the very large and talk about
cosmogenesis you know I would say why
are people so interested in this and all
you have to do is ask I'll ask you
what's what's your favorite day on the
calendar my favorite day on the calendar
I guess I'm supposed to say my birthday
but I won't is that what you were
looking for could be yeah could be your
birthday it could be your anniversary it
could be when your kids are born I wish
I could give you my anniversary I just
don't know it it's either October 9th or
October 10th Tracy
well thankfully both my wife and I both
completely get it mixed up so I'm going
to go for October 9th and I think you're
born on February 9th so the nth part of
that's true so uh a couple days before
Galileo's birthday on February 15th yeah
I always ask people that because usually
it's in it's the beginning of something
and people are always fascinating
beginnings and I think the universe is
no different and I think that explains
the surfit of ideas for cosmogenesis
right and uh among other things but but
when you look at the kind of spectrum of
of models we we discuss candidate
alternative
butamine work you've done and others we
both know have worked on thatp to
explain things other than uh requiring
inflation I'm thinking of conformal aycc
cosmology with our neutal friend sir
Roger Penrose um Paul steinhart and egis
Neil turro and their um they bouncing in
cyclical cosmologies uh even I my old
off my current office was occupied by
Jeff Burbage of of you know quasi steady
state cosmological Fame and I actually
talked to giant narar not too long ago
on the podcast the sole remaining
Survivor from the Quasi city state days
so uh when you look at these models a
lot of them start from the starting
point that inflation and the Multiverse
that comes concomitantly with it in most
models of inflation you have the
Multiverse Andre Lind said the same that
very thing on my very on this podcast
they find that distasteful Paul has said
Paul steinhardt good friend of mine has
said that not only is the Multiverse
dangerous to science it's dangerous to
society uh because it undermines the
efficacy of the 400y old scientific
method pioneered by our hero Galileo and
and many others so I want to ask is that
a Coos is that a valid reason to kind of
pursue Alternatives is a Multiverse so
anathema to not only let's leave Society
I think society's got its own problems
but what's your take is a Multiverse a
problem is it an opportunity well I have
to say I'm a little bit surprised that
Paul went that far in his critique of
the Multiverse because there is
something very real to say and he's been
saying it loudly and with intelligence
for a while which is the following if
you want to make predictions in the
context of a theory that involves other
universes you've got to have some means
of saying which universes are more
likely and which universes are less
likely because if all universes are out
there then all manner of physical
phenomenon all manner of observables all
manner of values of those observables
takes place in some universe and if you
have no means of saying well yeah those
universes are incredibly unlikely and
this one and that one are very very
likely and therefore I believe that
those values are the ones that are most
likely if you can't make that's right if
you can't make a statement like that you
are lost from the standpoint of making
predictions so Paul this is called The
Measure problem you want to be able to
place a measure to say this one's likely
and this one's not likely now that's a
scientific question to try to come up
with a means of assigning likelihood to
given universes it's not a problem that
we've cracked but there are many
proposals many mathematical ideas that
people have put forward and so I find it
surprising that Paul would go further
than that and say this is somehow
fundamentally like bad for science when
there's a real scientific issue on the
table and if you can resolve that scient
issue then this fits squarely within the
scientific method it's a little bit
different in detail but it's still you
have a idea you develop it
mathematically and from that you make
predictions because once you have a
measure you can make predictions so that
that's a little bit surprising but
coming back to your question yeah I
would say the following if we could
resolve all puzzles in physics without
recourse to a Multiverse my inclination
more like an aams razor approach would
be to take take those ideas most
seriously first but if we continually
run into a brick wall in trying to
answer fundamental questions in a single
Universe framework and we can answer
those problems in a Multiverse a
multi-universe framework we should at
least allow that to be part of our
toolkit we should allow it to be among
the ideas that we take seriously and
pursue it mathematically and for
instance try to answer this measure
problem M with that we are doing science
and so I think that to me is the most
rational and sensible way of thinking
about it and what about the syllogism
that you know we and I use this to you
know butter my bread in in the keing
household but you know that if you
measure gravitational waves in
primordial form via their imprint on the
cosmic microwave backgrounds B mode
polarization as we claim to do about 8
years ago uh and then recant it and now
have an opportunity to detect it again
for the first time uh with s's
Observatory bicep array and many other
experiments um if we do that then that
will be circumstantial but the strongest
possible evidence that we could hope to
measure of the epoch about a trillionth
of a trillionth of a trillionth of a
second after the big bang and therefore
that would be indirect evidence for the
Multiverse in fact on the day at which
the bicep 2 announcement took place
people like Max tegmark mutual friend
Max tegmark would say things like uh you
know hello gravitational waves hello a
Multiverse yeah uh and it was almost you
know almost two Hollywood perfect for
his book the mathematical Universe to to
resist so I want to ask you at what
level does that syllogism uh hold Curry
favor with you or hold water with you in
other words I tell you tomorrow Brian
here's some secret information s
Observatory measured it would you
believe the Multiverse more no so not
quite that quickly so generally speaking
I it's confirmed by the way yeah I get I
get but I would generally say the
following it's certainly the case that
if you have a theory that predicts a
Multiverse and also Al makes a whole
variety of other predictions that you
really can test and confirm in our
single Universe then of course that adds
weight to the prediction of things that
we can't confirm directly so yes I do
agree that evidence of a theory can
accumulate from observations in our
universe and that allows us to take
seriously predictions for things that we
can't yet see however it's also the case
that there may be competing explanation
for whatever it is that you're
confirming in this universe and those
other explanations may not involve a
Multiverse and indeed I think that's
where we're probably going in this
conversation because yes we're inflation
truly the only game in town the only
cosmological theory that can give us
insight into the cosmic microwave
background radiation solve the Horizon
problem solve the flatness problem give
us all of these insights into things
that we observe in our universe and also
by the way it predicts a Multiverse then
sure we'd be led in that direction and
yes you your example of finding that
primordial gravitational waves would be
one more piece of observational evidence
in our universe and that would be an
interesting and tidy story but there are
other ideas that people have put forward
and those proponents claim that they can
explain all the things that I just
mentioned the Horizon problem the
flatness problem and so on and so forth
and and that would be interesting to see
now in this very specific case that you
gave finding primordial gravitational
waves these competing theories in one in
particular Paul steinart doesn't give
rise to that Roger Theory doesn't give R
it doesn't rise to it but these are
simply the ideas that we've devel to
date and so I would not immediately jump
to the existence of a Multiverse if you
were to come with to me with that data
because I would say let's allow our
brains to continue to strive and see
whether there's a single universe theory
that does comport with everything again
I wouldn't rule out a Multiverse I've
written a whole book on the Multiverse
right so I'm not I'm not anti-
Multiverse not but I am reluctant to
jump so quickly to such a radical
proposal of other universes I would
rather say hey This lends Credence it
increases my basian probability that
that that this idea may be true however
I'm GNA still hope myself and others
Inspire others to continue looking for
more pedestrian explanations that don't
involve a Multiverse and if 10 or 15
years later 30 there nothing comes up
yes sure then then then it becomes even
more Lone Survivor just before we pivot
to our maybe final couple of topics if
you do you
you um I've definitely got my my second
and third win being here with you Brian
it's so exhilarating so you view the
Multiverse as a prediction actually I've
never I've never heard it phrase like
that in other words I've heard it phrase
as a consequence a paradigm but not a
prediction and I and I think that's an
interesting way to look at it because I
would say that inflation's very
successful when it comes to
retrodictions in that it explained you
know Dicky's conjecture of the the the
Paradox the fine-tuning of the of the
curvature of the universe that even in
the 70s they knew it was around one it
wasn't zero it wasn't infinity and then
the the you know the the oldness or the
and the Horizon problem those are kind
of retrodictions that you want your
theory to explain but the the novel
prediction and even um I do believe that
the that b modes or primordial tensor
pations in and of themselves per se are
actual PR are novel effects that would
falsify not prove inflation but falsify
alternative rival right so in that sense
what would you like to see in a can you
talk to God right and so you say to God
I want a candidate theory that replaces
I'll tell you what I would like I would
like for these alternatives to not have
the kind of sinanan of inflation which
is the inflaton field I would like to
have a theory and none of them have it
to date have a scaler field free version
of a cosmogenic event and maybe I'm
wrong because I'm not like searching
this uh sir Roger has the he doesn't
have a scalar field uh in the sense that
that Anna egis and and Paul steinhardt
do but he has these Arab bonds these
mysterious Dark Matter particles that
act like the creation field of of oil
and do you know it at a level of detail
I don't yeah I I don't know about that
so when if I was you know a good
theorist or a theorist at all I would
say I want to invent the theory that's
at least as least like inflation as
possible which means not having the Sy
quanon which means I'd like it to not
have a scalar field what is your minimal
Universe what would be the minimum
viable product that you would ship as a
theorist um you know to say that here's
an alternative to cosmogenesis that
doesn't look like inflation it doesn't
have this this these features in it what
would your minimum viable well I I I'm
not sure I would go in the direction
that you go okay I find inflation
actually a beautiful mathematical theory
Sure including a scaler field the most
simple kind of field that there is and
one that we now know does exist at least
the higs field is a specific example of
a scaler field so it's no longer this
hypothetical thing that it was when it
was first introduced into inflation now
we know there are fields that have this
quality called being spin zero and being
a scaler field it's a very beautiful
Theory it makes use of this spectacular
feature of Einstein's theory that
gravity can be repulsive as opposed to
just attractive that's a a beautiful
quality of the theory and it so
elegantly resolves many cosmological
problems that people scratched their
heads over before the theory was put
forward so I don't look at inflation and
say eh let's God do one better than that
that that's but what I would say is
inflation doesn't resolve all questions
for instance where did these fields come
from why is there a universe at all what
happens at Time Zero because even though
inflation changes the nature of Time
Zero it doesn't allow us to truly answer
the question of how things got started
in the first place it's still a theory
of how things evolve from a tiny
fraction of a second after whatever
created the environment and the
ingredients that allows the theory to
clock forward so those are the questions
that I would want you know the all
powerful being to to resolve or give a
theory that transcends inflation and can
Embrace answers to those questions so in
a sense the inflation may be that
minimum you aam aams cosmology and um I
want you to get your reaction you know
when physicists get older they they
devolve into the interpretations of
quantum mechanics but I want to get into
the interpretations of the Multiverse
having written books on this yourself
it's never been clear to me why in both
the Multiverse and the string landscape
why we say things like there'll be
different vacuum States and those could
lead to different not only different
concepts of nature but they could lead
to uh different laws of physics I've
heard that said and um and you're
shaking your head so maybe I'm maybe I'm
correct um I've certainly heard people
say such things I don't know if it's
actually true but my question to you is
perhaps a philosophical one why stop
there why not say actually there
different laws of mathematics and even
different different laws of so-called
predicate logic in other words in
different universes modus tolin doesn't
work and not only are as the different
is is g capital G 9.9 meters per second
Square you know or whatever yeah the
gravitational for lowercase G but it's
actually uh it doesn't follow that that
that you know if a then B and B doesn't
follow right so so yeah could that we
have a different laws of philosophy
mathematics so so it's an important
question to ask because the answer
requires that I spend just one minute a
little bit more detail on where the
Multiverse comes from say in in a theory
let's use string theory as as a as an
example or in string theory coupled with
inflation if you want to talk about you
know the process by which other
universes might come to be so the idea
is that there's one
overarching mathematical structure that
applies to all of these universes and
it's simply in string theory say that
the extra dimensions are curled up in
different ways in these different
universes but because the overarching
mathematical structure is still String
Theory it's just string theory in the
universe with the dimensions curled up
like this or string theory in Universe
with Dimensions curled up like that so
in that sense the equations are the same
and it's just environmental differences
the shape of the extra Dimensions you
know and and that's really all that it
is so that's why I would say it's not
even that the laws of physics vary from
Universe to Universe it's that the laws
of physics manifest in different ways
because the environment changes from
place to place I mean we're all familiar
gravity on the moon seems different than
gravity on Earth right astronauts can
jump whatever 20 feet into the air but
we all know that it's still the very
same law of gravity yeah that Newton
wrote down or Einstein whichever take
you know take your pick of accuracy it's
just that the environment is different
because the Moon is less massive than
the earth gravity manifests somewhat
differently on the moon than on Earth
and that's the way in which these
different universes differ same
overarching mathematical structure same
overarching formula but the way they
manifest can change based on the shape
of the extra Dimensions so that's why
it's not going to different Logics and
different different kinds of mathematics
it's really a uniform quality that
permeates all these universes now having
said that you can use your imagination
to imagine more robust versions of a
Multiverse where yeah you could imagine
that the kinds of mathematics that take
place is different you know Continuum
mathematics ptic mathematics or or the
different kinds of Logics can can differ
those multiverses though are coming
directly out of the human imagination
they're not coming out of a rigorous
mathematical Theory like string theory
or inflation cosmology it doesn't mean
that those ideas are wrong but they're
just less motivated because they're just
coming from a what if standpoint as
opposed to here's this Theory we study
it and oh my goodness Look what comes
out a Multiverse because they're
different ways for the extra Dimension
to be curled up or there are different
big bangs and say an inflationary
Multiverse giving rise to different
swelling domains Each of which should
rightly be called the universe of its
own those multiverses come directly out
of the mathematics and that limits the
ways in which those universes can differ
from each other each other I see okay
excellent so you are gonna pivot now uh
to two last topics one uh is uh
education and pedagogy and the last one
is aliens by law you know we must talk
about aliens and any it's either aliens
or Bitcoin which would you prefer BR up
to you yeah we go yeah they're kind of
the same but um all right send your hate
mail to this Brian not to this Brian um
so uh education yeah you're a renowned
educator I've learned tremendous amount
from you I saw you first met you in
person back in 1995 at Brown University
where I was a grad student you were I
believe moving from Cornell to to this
very location and your career and it was
you know uh what is it about the
anniversary or your book had just come
out maybe a couple years
earlier and um you've taught millions
and and you continue with your world
Science Festival that you have this
phenomenal team and you and your wife
are doing so much so much
first off how do you envision the role
of a scientist as an educator and I I'll
I'll make a bold statement I believe
it's my moral duty to have a podcast to
give a lecture to make a Tik Tok to do
something based on the fact hey I'm
teaching at a public university but all
of us were supported by the public we're
all serving at the larest of the
American taxpayer or whatever government
you're in or work for um or or live in
rather and um I believe that we we take
a lot and we would do this for free I
mean you and I have such pleasure and
finding what we do as a living I think
we do it for free more or less at least
I would I love building and tinkering
and playing around with physics but um a
lot of my colleagues will react
negatively to that they'll say no you
stay in your lane stay in the lab it's
too hard and we're not good at it um
obviously uh I I've never I haven't had
like much training in terms of like
podcast as you can probably tell I'm
always learning but you know I know that
people have have investigated it and I
also say to people I had a battle with
Sabina Hassen Felder who's my kogan
friend from from Germany who has a
wildly successful podcast and she said
yeah stay in your lane basically and I
said well why and she said well it's
really hard it's very difficult it's not
in the skill set of most scientists so
why force them to come out of the
laboratory to go into the and I said
Sabina you know to be fair like did you
come out of the womb knowing Quantum
field Theory no it was hard and you
learned it and to say that something is
hard so we shouldn't expect our students
and actually to teach them that
communication with the public who feeds
who pays is unimportant or that they
should ignore it I think we do that at
Great Peril not only to the public
understanding of science but to science
itself because once the public loses
faith in science and scientists that
we're just these specialized insects
working on one thing and that's too hard
for them to understand they're gonna
stop funding I would stop funding us
people said you're not smart enough to
understand what I do you can't even
explain it to somebody so I said a lot
but let me know what is your feeling on
the minimal obligation of a scientist to
explain his or her work to the general
public to
go out to the public and to explain what
you're doing you kind of got to enjoy it
right so I I get the feeling that you do
enjoy doing this narcissist so I love
doing self-promotion and and and and so
anybody you know there not all
physicists would like to be doing this
kind of work and so to imagine that
there's some moral responsibility or
that everybody should do it that seems
to me not necessarily a productive way I
hated linear algebra I mean I just I
justed it it was so boring it just wrote
memorization I wasn't good at it should
I not do it I mean because it's
uncomfortable or not easy for me well I
would say that you probably did it
because you wanted to learn quantum
mechanics is my guess right actually was
a like a civil engineering major for but
you had you had motivation to learn it
because you know but for you know some
physicists who are right at the edge I
mean you know take take someone like
Edward Whitten mhm right who's actually
a wonderful popularizer so this may not
be the best example but if you were to
say Edward you're not doing enough for
the public yeah you do some interviews
you did a Wonderful World Science
Festival program but you've got to have
your own podcast Edward morally speaking
you've got to be out there I don't think
it would be the right thing to force him
because I'd rather have the Edward doing
because he did the world science that's
right so so the point is I think every
physicist if we just stick to our needs
to determine for themselves how much
they want to do and how much they're
interested in doing and if there's some
who don't want to do it at all I'm
totally fine with that because I don't
feel like you should force someone to do
something of this sort let's not take
the wa example because you know I mean
it's just primis inter power or whatever
the Latin phrase is let's take your grad
student sure should she not do it isn't
it not good for her to develop
confidence talking to the public talking
to a camera talking and and purveying a
lot of what you and I do is persuasion
it's salesmanship and and we have to be
good at convincing funding agencies
tenure committees admissions you know
those are all those are all somewhat
different skill sets sure I know so so
it's certainly the case that students
need to learn how to write a grant and
in a grant you need to be able to
describe your work in a way that's
exciting and accessible and if you don't
do that it can have really negative
implication yes certainly on that front
and when I look at my own graduate
students there are some who absolutely
should go out into the world and some of
them have in terms of explaining there
are other of my graduate students that I
really do not think it would have been
the best thing for them to go out into
the world and and and and and many of
them them haven't but having said that
one of the things you mentioned the
world Science Festival we try to provide
a platform where scientists from around
the world can come and maybe not do a
podcast where it's going to be every
week but maybe come once a year yeah and
talk to the public in a way that can
really have impact so so yes I I partly
agree with you I think it's obviously
vital and important but I wouldn't
necessarily say that it's a moral
responsibility of everyone to do it
rather if you're driven to do it you
enjoy doing it and it's fun doing it and
it's productive doing it boming do it
you know I think you should try it and
see if it does appeal you fer water the
fertiliz ground see what comes up so but
sticking with education uh you and I are
part of an August profession you know
being I always say what's the proof
Brian that being a professor is the
greatest profession on Earth I don't
know if you have a proof I have a proof
um what was the only career suitable for
the most famous man on earth right after
he walked on the moon's surface Neil
Armstrong became a professor at the
University of cin is that true he was an
engineering professor and that's he
lived out the rest of his I think I got
have done anything um and he was very
satisfied in doing that um and and to
think that you know we get paid to do it
I would say it's like being you know
paid to taste chocolate or being a
wizard and you know Harry Potter um but
we get to do this great thing and yet
and yet our profession's pretty damn
sclorotic I bet you know when you were
at Oxford when I was at Brown you know
there was some person scratching on
there's a beautiful uh bepoke uh
chalkboard Flor to ceiling with your har
gumo chalk probably over there no it's
like Crayola how could you Brian uh
you're letting down generations of
theoretician um but there was some guy
or gal scraping on a rock with another
piece of rock as David ker always said
talks about it and this goes back to the
year 1080 in the University of bolognia
where the first Western University was
established and look okay we so I use
PowerPoint or keynote or rather okay not
much as change what do you see as
threats or opportunities for pedagogy in
the 21st century with maybe new tools
like artificial why should my students
learn from Brian keading when they can
learn from Brian Green virtually with an
avatar in 3D um you know at the speed of
light I think you're you're you're right
not that your student should learn from
me but that there are huge opportunities
so one of the things that we've been
developing are virtual reality
experiences we have a virtual reality
experience for middle school kids where
they can build stars and have them go
supernova we have another experience
where they play a game where as they
progress in the game they go faster and
faster getting closer to the speed of
light and all the weirdness of
Relativity comes out in the virtual
reality experience they can get a more
intuitive sense of these ideas so I
think is a huge opportunity using that
kind of medium for science to become
much more internalized as opposed to
just seeing it written on a Blackboard
in terms of Education itself I I agree
too you know a handful of years ago I
did a course you probably haven't seen
on special relativity where you know I
basically again it was a purely digital
course but I was using at that time
Cutting Edge technology which is
basically eight foot wide iPads in which
I didn't just use the chalk on a
chalkboard but I could write I could
show video I could do demonstrations and
so to me that for a personal proof of
concept that you could use these tools
to create look at that I just knocked
your microphone over sorry about that we
still working you know that you could
use these tools to to really radically
change the educational experience right
now we're doing a new course in quantum
mechanics which will be for the general
person but it's the full college level
quantum mechanics course chalk full of
visuals chalk full of interactive
demonstration so I I agree with you
there is a way to go beyond what we've
been doing for I usually say 500 years
but if you go back to 1080 gota go
you're taking you know almost a thousand
years you know so yeah I I absolutely
agree yeah I'm really excited about it
UCSD one of my colleagues is working on
AI avatars that use voice synthesis use
clothing from video game Unreal Engine
to synthesize Gandhi or I've I've Tak
Allan's works because they're all now
and I've digitized them and we have
aeman bot on mysite that you can
communicate with if he's sitting right
there now but you can imagine the the
visceral nature because people in maso's
hierarchy of needs and and you you look
at how do people learn and what it's the
Primacy of learning and the exposure and
the more visceral you make it the better
and I think you know you as an educator
you know are really kind of doing Yan's
work along with your with your team and
your crew how do you decide you know how
to allocate your time we talked about
what do but you're you're doing so much
with wsf and you're making time to do
you know podcasts with with nobody's
like me but but Brian how do you
determine like I'm gonna do an explainer
video I'm gonna do this fabulous Ted
Talk see my six million people I'm gonna
do wsf every single year for the past
what God 15 years unbelievable so how do
you decide just what's your what's your
day what's your workflow like well it
was the case years ago when I was a
assistant professor at Cornell which is
really when I started to to do stuff uh
more generally for the public my
strategy was pretty straightforward
which was I would do physics by day and
then sort of by 6: PM I'd go home eat
dinner and then I'd do the other stuff
by Night writing articles you know
writing books you know the elegant
Universe was written totally in the
evenings I diligently did not allow
these two different types of
undertakings to interfere with each
other but then what happens is you get
older you get married you got kids and
and now all of a sudden I you know
didn't evenings didn't exist any longer
to go WR a kids book yeah well that did
that that's that's true too but that's
when things really changed for me really
when I had my first child which I guess
that was
2005 and then it really came down to a
decision do I spend my time on X or on Y
and in the early days I struggled a lot
with that really trying to find the
balance okay I did this many hours of
res research this week I gotta do more
next week and it was that kind of thing
and finally I got to a place and I said
look life is
short and this struggle that I'm
creating for myself is totally in my own
head I can do whatever I want and I just
decided let me just do whatever feels
right at a given moment and so if it
felt right to jump into a book and that
meant that research projects had to go
on hiatus or even on complete hold so be
it then some interesting research
project would crop up at some point
later and say drop the book and work on
the research product because that's the
most exciting thing at a given moment so
I stopped evaluating it I stopped
judging myself and I said let me just
live as an individual who likes to do
research and to write books and you know
I've written stage pieces you we had
things of that s World Science Festival
programs I like these kinds of
conversations you know and let me just
go with the flow and see where it leads
and that's been a perfectly fine and
happy way going forward you know so
we're coming up this Thursday I believe
is the 90th birthday of Carl Sean
speaking of of Cornell and uh Carl of
course is known for many things but one
of my favorite things that that he did I
guess he did it with Icarus at the edge
of time um it was write a fiction book
and fiction book is called Contact
Loosely based on our past guest and also
Cornell alumna and last name maen name
Cor which is Jill Tarter uh and of
course these are subjects revolving
around our final topic which is ANS so
much is in the zeist of aliens the
spirit of the time the the news Cycles
we've had NASA Panel LED by the
president of the Simons Foundation David
spurgle eminent uh National Academy of
Science uh member uh leading a NASA
panel to talk about these unidentified
aerial phenomena what do you make of
this what do you make of the
eyewitnesses I've had on a couple on my
podcast Navy fighter pilots um doing
stuff I could never have The Bravery or
physical fitness to do obviously um what
do you make about these the eyewitness
reports the um the kind of technical uh
uh you know um I say identification or
examination how do you look at as a
scientist how should a scientist look at
it look obviously the the right person
to answer that question is say a David
spergo someone who's really looked at
the data and been on a committee to try
to evaluate whether or not there's
anything to this stuff but if you ask me
on the outside my sort of gut feeling is
it's all nonsense why do I say that well
for following simple reason you know if
an alien civilization had the capacity
to travel across the Galaxy you know
Interstellar distances do you really
think that they'd be sort of hanging out
so that a fighter pilot could spot them
and like oh my God and they try to get
out of the way really quickly and they
just get caught on camera I mean it just
seems so incredibly ludicrous to me and
then when you think of it in the context
of time scales right life on planet
Earth evolved pretty quickly half a
billion years after the Earth formed
couple billion years later we start to
get multicellular organisms intelligence
then follows relatively quickly upon
that so let's say billions of years is
the time scale for intelligence now that
would suggest that if there are other
intelligent beings out there and they'd
have to be pretty intelligent to be
floating around in our
atmosphere they are likely at a time
scale that differs from us by the order
of a billion years right it's not as
though the clock said go and evolution
started on planet Earth and Planet yeah
on Planet X simultaneously like a thing
is Planet X if they're able to do
interesta travel they're not just a
hundred years ahead they're likely a
billion years ahead and a billion years
ahead just think about it we'd be so un
interesting to them right how often do
you stop and get down on all fours and
speak to ants in an antill you proba I
don't want to say I don't want to say
one of my hobbies you don't do it often
because it's not interesting and if H
other civilizations a billion years
ahead of usson would disagree with well
that's right that's right so there are a
few but um the point is there's probably
a billion-year difference in our
evolutionary development and so the idea
that they'd be just in a ship kind of
looks like our ships or in a flying
saucer that kind of looks like the
flying saucers that we imagine no they'd
be a billion years ahead they would be
traveling in ways that we can't even
fathom and so the idea that we're just
kind of catching them is so ludicrous to
me and more pedestrian explanations that
I've heard banded about weather
satellites interesting phenomena light
band bounces off you know those
explanations seem to be much more likely
to me and when you put it in the context
of everything that I just said it just
kind of feels ludicrous yeah I mean
often you hear that these objects defy
the laws of physics and you know one of
the things I always point out was that
you know if there were a military you
know uh campaign to mock or so Discord
or or do whatever they would make things
that would appear to violate the laws of
physics my favorite uh you know kind of
uh analog here is Louis Alvarez in World
War II had these uh radar jamming and
spoofing mechanisms that as an Allied
plane would get closer to the to the
German forces it would actually
broadcast weaker and weaker radar
signals to it declining as the inverse
fourth power as a reflected signal would
so they thought oh this thing's getting
uh CL farther and farther and it's
really getting closer and closer
therefore to the radar operator in
Berlin these things defi the laws of
physics but they had a perfectly P now I
want to distinguish between
extraterrestrial intelligent and crafts
and life elsewhere in the universe so I
think where where do you come down in
that Spectrum are we alone first and
foremost and then the secondary question
of you know can we actually learn from
or I would say no one would like them to
be aliens to be visiting us more than a
physicist because we'd be learning so
much about them if they don't eat us or
you know focus with the magnifying glass
like I used to do with my Ants but but
I'm not going to talk about those crimes
against antology um so tell me Life in
the universe yeah I mean obviously we we
don't know and there's this famous
thing called the Drake equation which I
always recoil when people call it an
equation it's just an encapsulation of
ignorance and a variety of terms yeah
you know so look as we now have
discovered what 5,000 plus exoplanets
we're pretty convinced that planet
circling stars is the norm it's not the
exception so there could be hundreds of
billions if not trillions of planets in
our own Galaxy and our galaxy is one of
hundreds of billions so there's so many
opportunities for life of the sort that
we're familiar with to take hold on a
planet someplace out there so when you
take that into account and note that we
now have evidence for you know amino
acids and you know these things these
these molecules necessary for Life seem
to be relatively ubiquitous they're not
that hard for to to to synthesize and to
to be on any of these other planets
we'll we'll know for sure pretty soon
with the James web Space Telescope
studying the atmospheres of variety
exoplanets how could you not say yes I
think it's reasonably likely that
there's other life out there I think a a
slight contrarian Viewpoint all these
things not just in the Extraterrestrial
tell as a guard against confirmation
bias and of the sort that I would love
for there to be extra you know to ask
questions to see if you're right about
String Theory now that wasn't
intelligence I'm saying no no just but
I'm also a contrar a pessimist when a
minimalist when it comes to even life
because I say like what if I told you
Brian one of those exoplanets I I just
heard you know from one of my friends
and you can't check your phone to see if
I'm true or not if I'm telling the truth
or not but uh she told me that actually
there's a planet and there's a binary
Planet system it's it's it's near a
gtype yellow subdwarf just like our son
and one of those they're both in the
habitable zone these two planets
different orbits slightly different
orbits they don't interact
gravitationally but um one of them is
teaming with life it has life and every
extrem ofic location you could possibly
imagine um and we don't know yet because
the James web has you know got a over
and look at it or what have you um and
actually see if there's you know there's
city lights on this one planet and I
said what do you think as a good basian
I hope you are otherwise we can't be
friends no but as a basian what would
you say the probability is for the twin
planet the other planet maybe it's in
the same orbit maybe slightly outside
the orbit in the habitable zone same
composition so what would you say as a
guess at the probability that there's
also at least single cell organisms on
that planet it seems seems reasonable
pretty high right so I would say well we
have that example it's called Mars right
so Mars is in the habitable zone but
yeah it's also a dynamical question
right so in fact it could be that life
on planet Earth originated on Mars I
mean you know so so where I'm going yeah
yeah okay so so the non-observation of
life right now at least to the to to our
understanding we it could be Lava Tubes
and Avil lobe our friend up at Harvard
thinks that he might find the alien
skeletons you know scraped on the side
of the cave which I want you all to do
out there you know the four words that
are most important to humanity please
like And subscribe but the fact that we
haven't observed it not a lack of
evidence as as your friend of mine Carl
Sean used to say it's not evidence of
lack but at the same token we should be
able to set some Bas in you know prior
reduction based on the non-observation
of Life anywhere in the now maybe we'll
find it tomorrow so I'm just saying
there there there seems to be this
prediction as Carl and Andrian who was
also on my podcast a long time ago Carl
wasn't but Ann was and their daughter
Sasha was on and it was wonderful but as
they said in contact they said well if
there's no life out there it's an awful
waste of space now I've been to
Antarctica twice I spent over a month of
my life been there once you have you've
been to the South Pole I Trump you okay
fine I have one thing over you Brian
come on you're my avatar uh but um not
much life there there's more penguins
than people and even there aren't that
many penguins in Antarctica there's no
life at the South Pole besides the
people that are there so just by saying
there's there's possibility of life like
these exop totally age about the actual
problem okay yeah yeah no I I I
completely agree with that and so that's
why why I say it a little bit
factiously that look the ingredients
seem to be out there and there seems to
be a lot of opportunity for the
ingredients to take hold but in
detail even giving a different example
what if we find that life on Earth only
took hold because of this incredibly
obscure phenomenon that we've yet to
identify and that phenomenon is so
incredibly rare that it perhaps never
happens any anywhere even if you got a
100 trillion you know that this is
something that's at least possible 10 to
the 25th that's right that's right so so
if it's you know 10 to the minus 100
likelihood for this obscure process now
we've not found evidence for any such
obscure you know but you know until we
synthesize life in the laboratory and we
actually know hey all you need are these
very basic a little bit of you know
electric current a little C manifold
yeah that' be a little bit too far but
you know if you can synthesize it in the
laboratory and it's really damn easy to
do then the likelihood of finding it
elsewhere I would air much more on the
side of saying yeah I'm now much more in
the camp of this is lik to happen but
until we do that no it could be that
we're missing something deep well Brian
I wan to thank you so much and I always
conclude with your Indulgence of a few
more minutes with a following four
questions that are existential in origin
but to get those just as long as it's
not why is this night different from all
other that's coming up that's coming up
in the in the spring we will touch upon
something related to that but if you
want to hear Brian's answers to these
you have to subscribe to my mailing list
I'll have links to subscribe to the
world Science Festival and all Brian's
cool stuff and um and that is at
bring.com list and if you have a.edu
email address because I love students
and I want to encourage students to
develop their communication skills and
learn from these conversations you're
guaranteed to win a meteorite a chunk of
four billion year old space Schmutz from
the pre uh pre-earth uh environment of
our solar system so that's at Brian
king.com so go over there if you want to
hear that and the answers to Brian's
final four questions uh but before we go
I just want to give you a business tip a
business proposal and that's uh you ever
see these things you can buy a star
Brian you can get a star name star Nam
yes I think I may have even done it once
that's what I was I was hoping you say
because I have an idea for you and this
is free of charge and you feel free to
use it why buy just a star when you can
buy a universe within the Multiverse
that is the world Universe registry in
the Multiverse Brian Green thank you so
much for being on the into the
impossible podcast my pleasure thank you